sonntag mein name ist claudia streaming
ich führe stichprobenartige kontrollen
zur bevorratung unserer staatsbürger
durch um so was kümmert sich mein mann
kommen sie mal mit in den keller peter
für dich
sie wissen aber schon dass ich sie töten
muss wenn sie da unten alles gesehen
haben
dass ein scherz oder
ja klar aber wer weiß schon
[Musik]
hallo
hallo mein name ist claudia stremming
ich komme vom bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
hat seehofer nennt ich meine brief
übergeben seehofer nein ich bin nicht in
der altenpflege tätig meine aktuelle
chefin heisst nancy faeser egal ich habe
über 100 briefe geschickt um sie darauf
aufmerksam zu machen wie sie die
bevölkerung vor waren müssen das als
eine riesensauerei dann kennen sie ja
sicherlich unseren ratgeber für
notfallvorsorge und richtiges handeln in
notsituationen
was das finish was in die kiste mit dem
kram würde ich nicht mal übers
wochenende nach holland fahren albern
dann beginnen wir doch mal mit der
visite haben sie pro person 20 liter
wasser vorrätig um ihr nacktes überleben
für zehn tage zu sichern
und wenn dann doch keinen atomkrieg
kommen können sie von den flaschen von
der ihren ruhestand finanzieren
machen sie ruhig ihre sprüche aber
irgendetwas wird kommen
blackout chemiekatastrophe
überschwemmungen
bürgerkrieg
dann bin ich ja richtiggehend gespannt
auf ihre lebensmittelvorräte wir
empfehlen ja 6,5 kilogramm gemüse
hülsenfrüchte obst und nüsse professor
prozent
sage wohlgemerkt
meine frau kocht schon seit jahren alles
mögliche einführung garten finden
was sie so im garten finden mein gott
die katze die sie schon seit
naja immerhin
proteine
und was ist hier drin etwa ganz
vorbildlich 3,5 kilogramm
getreideprodukte 3,5 tonnen korn sind
gar nicht so leicht zu beschaffen da
ist uns dann vielleicht auch bei der
bestellung an keiner fehler unterlaufen
[Applaus]
aber bald ist das hier ein komplett
künstlich beleuchteten plantage
unabhängiger geht nicht die originell
und damit wollen sie dann wandern gehen
wenn die ganze welt in staub und asche
zerfallen ist ja ich war
so ein quatsch ich möchte
danke ich bin sogar eine flucht
bundesliga
schlafsack kocher und passt diese
kooperation
mit den vorräten kann der fünfköpfige
familie drei wochen morgen locker
übernehmen
sowie im thailand urlaub bevor ich drei
wochen aus dem rucksack lebe da
akzeptiere ich lieber den weltuntergang
das ist ja auch alles nur für nova hier
dagegen haben wir es uns richtig
gemütlich gemacht
in diesem schlaf sei da kann man im
ernstfall erst mal wieder zu kräften
kommen eine richtige oase spüren sie
dass ruhe und erholung
wenn sie heimlich punkt ab und gratis
was hier gibt es keine party doch ich
habe eine schärfere tür als das gar kein
aber ohne die musik der konzern hier
einfach nur wie nützlich ist wir haben
hier eine knallharte elitetruppe ja also
also der jürgen der arzt und die martina
die alten jagdschein
bernd dass metzger h thomas war damals
der einzige der nicht verweigert hat und
ach so na ja dann liegt hier natürlich
noch tango thorsten sandhaus aber klar
thorsten
hallo thorsten leute seid ihr gut drauf
du scheiße
brot und spiele fällt das volk ruhig
hier gibt's eine bestechende musik
liegt aber hier ist nur ein blick drauf
meint genügen aber auch in einen tagebau
[Musik]
sowas primitives haben wir gar nicht
nötig ich hingegen habe vor ein paar
jahren bei ein zwei gläschen wodka einen
deal eingetütet 3 vorstellen nord stream
soll ich sagen ich hab mein meister
gefunden seien hätten schutzraum werde
ich nie wieder zu gesicht bekommen
ich bringe sie noch nach vorne bis zur
tür aber
ganz ehrlich es tut gut dass man von
offizieller seite zu hören darf ich hier
bleiben
ich weiß beim besten willen dich was wir
hier für eine verwendung für sie hätten
schon mal was von krav maga
[Musik]
ich bin übrigens die klauen
macht euch bereit für die zukunft bleibt
informiert also abonniert diesen kanal
rust was denn das zeug muss er weg
platzmangel
[Musik]
kann diese scheiße zu spielen